people who are healthy people who learn
and grow and progress see their lives in
terms of redemption narratives not as
perfect but as better as going in that
kind of trajectory and so when we think
about these our lives and narrative
terms we inevitably have to ask the
question okay my life is a narrative am
i the author of that narrative or am i a
character in that name
what's modern society's problem with
regret
uh we
we dismiss it as something that should
be avoided rather than embrace it as
something that can actually change our
lives
and i think it's part of a bigger
problem with modern society and that we
don't know how to deal with negative
emotions
we
think that negative emotions make us
weak we think that negative moments are
dangerous when in fact negative emotions
can make us strong and negative emotions
can make us better particularly our most
common negative emotion regret
that's the most common negative emotion
yeah there's some interesting research
starting in the 1980s um where they as a
social scientist named susan shimanov
who did research in in the us where she
recorded everyday conversations among
people and then they took the transcript
of these conversations and they coded
the conversations for the emotions that
were expressed the most common negative
emotion people express is regret the
second most common emotion overall that
people discuss is regret the only second
only the love so regret is regret isn't
it is a ubiquitous emotion everybody has
regrets the only people who don't have
regrets are people with some kind of um
problem people who have
neurodegenerative disease or people who
are sociopaths
otherwise everybody has regrets why is
it so common
well that's a great question and and i
think that's the puzzle that you know
i'd love your listeners to to linger
have your listeners linger in their head
for a little bit because here you have
this emotion that is unpleasant right
okay so let's not regret it doesn't feel
good regret feels bad it feels bad it's
a negative emotion and yet it's
ubiquitous so
that's a great that's a great way to
frame the issue why is it hard
why is regret both hard to take and hard
to avoid
and there's a little bit of a paradox
here because you say well wait a second
we human beings are wired for pleasure
we seek pleasure why is is something
that's so unpleasant so ubiquitous and
the answer is
it's good for us
it helps it's useful it's there for a
reason and what we know from 50 years of
science is that our cognitive machinery
is pre-programmed for regret regret is
actually an important and integral part
of how our brains work and so when we
embrace this idea that we shouldn't have
regrets that we shouldn't look backward
that we should dismiss negative emotions
we are doing ourselves a grave
mis-service
how's the brain programmed for regret
well you have to say
that's our the brain is prone to regret
because regret helps us learn okay so
just think about this let's let's let's
use internet let's use an analogy all
right imagine if we didn't let's go back
to this big issue of negative emotions
okay imagine if we didn't have the
emotion of fear
we wouldn't survive right you're in it
your hotel is on fire i'm not scared of
a burning building in new york city and
you end up melting on your you know your
your desk chair in some hotel right all
right uh um you know imagine imagine a
world without grief
um uh which is a terrible emotion right
but imagine if we didn't experience
grief
the reason we experienced grief is
because we experience love right grief
is teaching us something it tells us
something and regret teaches us regret
regret clarifies it's part of our
cognitive machinery because regret more
than any other emotion in our life
clarifies what we care about and
instructs us how to do better if we
treat it right we don't always treat it
right
clarifies what we care about and
instructs us to do better
yes
so it's
it's to do with it's both a forward and
back
yeah well it's it's interest that's a
great point it's it's both okay and
those two things are inextricable what
regret does is that we look backward
feel the stab of negativity for
something we did or didn't do for us for
a decision we made or didn't make all
right that stab of negativity
clarifies what matters to us and
instructs us about what we do next and
so and and it's a great it's interesting
you picked up on that because it's it's
integral to
our understanding of regret and it's
integral to understanding how in some
ways majestic and extraordinary it is
that we can experience regret this is
one reason why the five-year-olds for
instance don't experience regret because
their brains haven't developed enough
with regret let's let's say
let's say that um
let's say that um i regret i don't give
you a guy i regret that i didn't um
i regret that i didn't study
um accounting when i was when i was
younger okay so imagine no one has ever
said that
okay so give me some philosophy
philosophy i regret okay perfect i
regret okay great i regret that i didn't
study philosophy when i was younger okay
so think about think about what i had to
do with that first of all i go back in
time to when i was in university which
is 35 years ago right so i'm already
i've already sort of cognitively gotten
in a time machine
zip back there
i know what really happened there but
i'm also going to use my incredibly
inventive mind to negate what really
happened so i'm gonna so i'm a fabulous
too i'm gonna tell an entirely new story
where i studied philosophy right then
i'm not done all right then i get back
in my time machine and i zip to the
present
all right and i say wow if only i
studied philosophy
and as i did in my recreated past i've
now arrived at it at a present but the
present has been reconfigured because my
past decisions and i'm now
a more enlightened person i'm now more
attractive to women because i can talk
about hume and i can talk about spinoza
uh i i have a better sense of what my
life is about and and and so and so it's
about time travel and fabulism and it is
incredibly cognitively sophisticated um
it is very hard for me to imagine
another species doing that i mean that
very seriously i think that we we know
we're learning a little bit more about
animal emotion and cognition um and and
we know that that we know there's some
animals that seem to experience grief we
know that most animals experience some
kind of attachment and something akin to
love
but regret it's just too cognitively
sophisticated it's one of the things
that makes human beings unique and and
so why has it why has it maintained why
has it not been washed out through
evolution it's actually been enhanced
through evolution because it's useful
what's the opposite of regret is it
gratitude
no i think the opposite of regret is is
maybe rejoicing
i think the opposite of to regret
something is to rejoice it to say oh i'm
so glad i made that i'm so glad i didn't
study philosophy because i'd be a
barista right now i'm so glad i didn't
study philosophy because because
schopenhauer had no idea what he was
talking about you know i'm so glad i i
didn't you know that's it's a it's a
rejoicing
yeah it's interesting i was just
wondering why
well we have a negativity bias
and
learning lessons from what's effective
is important but it's less effective
it's less important than learning the
things that could have killed you or
went you know terrifyingly wrong so i'm
trying to think about
how if there's a scale or if you know if
a little bit of rejoicing can dampen the
pain of regret at all
well
yes and no i mean there are things that
you can do okay so so let's let's take
it let's take a step back
so in the broad architecture of regret
there are often two kinds of regret
regrets of action and regrets of
inaction regrets about what you did and
regrets about what you didn't do
all right so
with action regrets
you can
you have
some options with an action regret let's
say that i have hurt somebody
i can
try to make amends i can try to make
restitution i can apologize with certain
action regrets let's say oh my gosh i
can't believe i painted my house orange
well you can repaint your house
a more congenial color so you can undo
certain action regrets the other thing
you can do with action regret which
you're hinting at chris is that you can
mitigate some of the pain
by what i call it leasting them which is
uh and this is what i mean by that
our ability to process regret is
logicians philosophers uh along with
scientists paul
uh counterfactual thinking we can we can
we can summon a world that runs counter
to the actual facts right and so they're
different kinds of counterfactuals you
can do a an upward counter factual
imagine how things could have been
better if only i'd studied philosophy
right that makes you feel worse but it
makes you do better you can also do a
downward counter factual well at least i
studied accounting and i have a good job
so you can do a downward counter factual
this the classic example of this is is
with um is why in the olympics
um bronze medalists are happier than
silver medalists routinely if you look
at their faces bronze medalists say ah
at least i got a medal unlike the schmoe
of finished fourth silver medals are
saying oh if only i kicked a little
harder i'd have a gold medal right so so
so what we know getting back to action
and inaction regrets is that with action
regrets
we can at least then we can say and i
have and i've collected all these
regrets from around the country around
the world rather and you you can say oh
well i regret marrying that idiot but at
least i have these three great kids um
and you can and think about these
downward counterfactual things at least
is that they make us feel better they
don't necessarily help us do better but
it's okay to feel better i mean
sometimes that's actually useful
what were the most common regrets that
you found
well let me instead of asking that
question directly let me stay on brand
and give you a lengthy discursive and
contextual preamble before answering the
question um so what i did is on that one
is so in order to research this book one
of the things that i did is i looked at
the academic research i did my own
public opinion survey a quantitative
survey of the u.s population and then i
also collected
um
in in the book itself we had 15 000
we're now over 18 000 18 000 regrets
from people all over the world and what
i found is that
around the world people have the same
four core regrets over and over and over
again and they're less about the domains
of people's lives than they are about
something underneath that's going on
there so let me give you one of those
these four core regrets to try to
exemplify that um i have a lot of
regrets about people who regret
um
uh not traveling not traveling enough
okay so that's like in this sort of
personal category oh i had a chance to
go to greece but i didn't do it i had a
chance to try i had a chance to study
when uh overseas when i was in
university and i didn't take the chance
okay a lot of a lot of people regret not
studying abroad in university right so
that's an education regret then i have
lots and lots and lots and lots and lots
and lots of regrets all over the world
where someone regrets
finding somebody attractive
wanting to ask them out
not doing it
and then regretting that that that that
chickening out okay so that's a romance
regret and then i have lots of regrets
about people who say i stayed in this
crappy job but what i really wanted to
do was start my own business but i
didn't have the guts to do it that's a
career regret but to my mind those are
all the same regret those are a regret
you're at a juncture you can play it
safe you can take the chance you don't
take the chance and you regret it so one
category of boldness regrets which are
if only i'd taken the chance
um and then there's there are three
others that i'm happy to talk about too
and that's an inaction regret that first
one
the boldness one is definite boldness is
almost always an inaction regret there
they're actually relatively few it's
interesting question they're relatively
few people i mean again i got this
massive database of regrets
there are people who regret acting too
bold
but
they are the distinct minority i would
say there's a
i mean i i don't
40 to 1 ratio 50 to 1 ratio of people
who regret up between people who regret
not acting bold enough and people who
were acting too bold
it seems to me that it's overwhelming
it's overwhelming it seems to me like
maybe maybe adventure
is is kind of like a little bit of a
common theme in that boldness stuff that
you're thinking about like this if only
i'd been a little bit braver maybe i
would have had new experiences seen new
people had a different sort of life
i i think it's partly adventure i think
that it is i think there's even
something bigger than adventure going on
chris and it's in
um
um i'll i'll see your
i'll see your adventure and raise you
mortality i think that at some level
all of us human beings are conscious
that we're mortal
uh that we're not here forever it's an
existential thing
yeah i think that it is i think that
it's partly existential it's basically
saying we are here on this planet for an
astonishingly brief amount of time so
when am i going to do something when am
i going to see stuff when am i going to
learn when am i going to grow there's a
there's an emerging field in
psychological science
around the concept of something called
psychological richness that not only do
we want a pleasant life but we want a
psychologically rich life that which
would include things like adventure and
i think that's what's driving that i
think that's what's driving the boldness
regrets well i suppose the thing with
the boldness regret is that if i've
behaved this way in the past i'm
concerned that if i continue to behave
this way in the future as life continues
to become less and less and less
available as we get older and we're
getting closer toward death that's where
the existential thing comes in right
look i did this thing in the past and if
i continue to do this thing in the
future as life gets even more sparse and
there's even less life for me to have
i'm going to potentially fritter away
more of my days not doing things that
actually fulfill me existentially
i think you're spot on and i have data
to prove that because on that so so the
second piece of the
research that i did was it was a large
uh public opinion survey a quantitative
survey of the u.s population so we
surveyed 4 489 americans asking them all
kinds of questions about regret and what
it means and what they regretted and
and what i was really looking for were
demographic differences do men have
different regrets than women do yeah um
and the demographic differences were
much less pronounced than i would have
expected except
on what you're talking about and it's
this
when we are young say in our 20s
people tend to have equal roughly equal
numbers of action regrets and inaction
regrets but as we age
it's all in action not all but it's
inaction regrets take over for exactly
the reason that you're saying i think is
that the finish line is a little bit
closer and
people say holy smokes i still haven't
done that i gotta step up
it's kind of common mean culture you
know to talk about you're supposed to uh
you never regret the things that you do
only the things that you didn't do
i think i've seen that posted around on
the internet a lot i don't know i don't
know why
it's not true it's not that you never do
but i don't know why people have picked
up on that particular mechanic that
there is a skew toward inaction being
more painful or at least more prevalent
than
action
yeah um it's it's more prevalent i'm not
sure it's always more painful but it's
but it's more prevalent i mean i there
are all kinds of reasons for that num
one of them is that
as we were talking about earlier is that
with action regrets you can actually you
can do something about them so you know
so i got a guy in the book who
uh
got a no a tattoo that said no regrets
then regretted it and got it removed
okay so that's a way of undoing you know
like action regrets you can you can you
can you can sometimes do something about
until you can resolve them and in action
regret let's say i regret never visiting
turkey all right um
how do i i can't
there's only one solution to that you
know i got to go do it and if i don't do
it i'm still hit by that and the other
thing is that people tend to be bothered
by the what ifs and what's interesting
about some of the boldest regrets and
some of the other regrets is that people
were less outcomes than i expected um
they weren't saying i should have asked
her out on a date i should have asked
him out on the date not because they say
oh and as a consequence of that i would
have had this blissful marriage
they just they're not saying that
they're saying
i just want to know what would have
happened
oh so a lot of this is it's closing that
sort of zygotic loop a little bit it's
wanting
to just lock that off so that they know
what would have happened yeah i think
about this a lot so here's some uh bro
science cod psychology for you uh coming
later
straight out of the research lab that is
my brain um
i'm pretty sure that
there is something called an anxiety
cost so opportunity cost is
going to the theme park or going to the
gym you choose to go to the theme park
the cost of going to the theme park is
not going to the gym right that's
opportunity cost i'm pretty sure that
there's an equivalent that occurs
when
for instance in your daily routine
everything that you need to do as a part
of your daily routine sets when you wake
up on a morning let's say that you're
going to meditate and take the dog for a
walk and go to the gym and do some other
things
the longer that you wait throughout your
day until you do that thing
the more time of your day is spent
ruminating and thinking about the fact
that you still need to do that thing so
let's say that you'd gone to the gym and
walked the dog and done your meditation
first thing in the morning you could
have basked for the remainder of the day
reveling in this sort of productive glow
that you've had well look i've already
done those things i don't need to take
my time thinking about that however if
you don't go to the gym until 6 p.m you
will spend a non-zero amount of time
earlier in the day thinking oh well i've
still got to go to the gym i've got that
thing to do i can't believe i got that
thing to do and that to me is the
anxiety cost so the sooner that you can
get certain tasks done the sooner that
you can
the equivalent could be done with
thinking about asking a girl out there's
a girl in college you really want to ask
out you could spend the next two years
of college thinking about asking her out
or you could do it now stress test the
idea and you won't have to ever think
about that anymore now that to me that
anxiety cost is such a motivator you
think look if i just go and do the thing
and it it seems given the fact that uh
action and inaction skews toward
inaction being more prevalent
it seems like that might help to
actually push people okay i'll just do
it i'll just do it i know that inaction
is a more consistent regret
uh than action ones and i know that i'm
not gonna have to think about it again
if i just get it done she might have
halitosis she might be a total [ __ ]
i'll ask her
uh so here's the thing i i think that
one of the lessons of this is that we
should have
something of a bias for action
um
and because for a couple of reasons
number one is that i think under under
for there are a few reasons why i think
we should have a bias for action
number one for exactly the reason that
you're saying that it extinguishes the
what-if question
and the what-if question can linger on
us as a i mean you're essentially
describing it as something of a
cognitive tax
um it's a tax on our on our attention
it's a tax on our
uh willpower it's a tax on our
um
uh you know ability to focus in a way so
um and so the the action extinguishes
that the other thing which i think we
we've totally
underestimated is how much action helps
us learn
that is
we we tend we sometimes have the
sequence wrong we think that the way you
do stuff is you learn how to do it and
then you do it but a lot of times doing
stuff helps us learn what to do and how
to do it um it's certainly true when
we're thinking about our
it's certainly true when we're thinking
about our life course or when we're
thinking about what to do with our lives
we tend to say okay i got to plan this
out and then i'm going to do it but the
way you discover what it is you want to
do is by doing stuff and so i think a
lesson of these boldness regrets is that
we should have
you know i don't i don't think a wild
bias toward action but we should have a
bias toward action uh because action
extinguishes our what if and it helps us
learn in ways that we don't often
realize what was the next category of
regrets after boldness so another
another category of regret or what i
call foundation regrets foundation
regrets are people who regret say
uh spending too much money and saving
too little
people who regret not taking care of
their health people who regret not
working hard enough in school or
university people who make these small
decisions they're they're largely about
conscientiousness about prudence small
decisions early that have
that accumulate and have pretty nasty
consequences later on
and um and so foundation regrets if all
these regards are only taking the chance
foundation regrets are if only i've done
the work and what they show is their
need for stability um a good life
has is not precarious it's hard to have
a good life if you're uncertain if your
platform is wobbly and people do regret
making bad small decisions that have a
the collective force of
weakening their foundation of
of
giving too much precariousness to their
life
it's so interesting how these regrets in
retrospect are reminding us of a lot of
things that we're told when looking
forward you know you need to look after
your health you should be going to the
gym you should be careful about how you
spend your money and in retrospect we're
being told that this is
uh
like mimetic evolution is is providing
us with okay what are the things that
after the entirety of life still stick
in somebody's mind is to think now
that's not to say that the things that
they say that they regret would have
actually improved their lives had they
have done them but they certainly
wouldn't have regretted them anymore
you got it exactly right this is the
part we were talking about earlier
regret is clarifying the stuff that
sticks with us teaches us what we value
what we what we value and i think that
what we value is stability uh we value
stability but we also value boldness at
the same time those things are those
those things are perfectly compatible i
i and
you know i say this in the book is what
what these four regrets reveal in some
ways is a photographic negative of the
good life that is i got these sixteen
thousand now i mean again eighteen
thousand people who are telling me what
they regret the most
but by doing that they're telling me
what they value the most
and these four core regrets tell us what
people value the most and two of the
things they value is they want some
people a good life that has some
stability to it but a good life also has
some growth and some psychological
richness and some existential excitement
and adventure to it as you're saying
what's the next category
moral regrets
those are regrets where people are at a
juncture in their life they can do the
wrong thing they can do the right thing
they do the wrong thing
and they regret it
um and these are things like
um the two biggest areas are bullying
um in in school
a lot huge numbers of that and then
marital infidelity things that
that that violate
either that person's individual moral
codes or a broader moral code
um and and i think that that suggests
that people actually and i'm convinced
of this i think most people i really do
most people want to be good i'm
convinced that that um
not not you know when we can we can i
mean i think there's an evolutionary
argument for that for um
but i think that most of us want to be
good and most of us not every single
person every single time but most of us
feel pretty bad when we we don't act
well we don't we're not good yeah well i
mean the regrets
aren't signaling to a group
you know maybe it'll make you act in a
certain way but it's very much an
internal
singular that's a very good it's a very
good point that's a really really that's
a very very good point about that and
that's that's a great point actually and
that's why it is
that's a great point that's why it's so
instructive because it's it's inherently
not performative right so the the
expression of no regrets is a
performance if i say to the world i have
no regrets i never look backward that's
performative i am performing courage but
when i feel regret and it's coming this
way there's no performance there it's an
honest signal to yourself yeah it's an
honest signal you can have a fair bit of
faith that the things that you regret
are things that you actually regret
now did you find
or can you imagine that certain people
may
overly regret
people may um tune up absolutely tune up
their regrets too high
there's no question about that and this
is this is because we haven't been
taught effectively how to deal with
negative emotions
um and so
so on one pole you can ignore your
negative emotions that's a bad idea that
leads to delusion but on the other pole
you can wallow in them you can ruminate
over them that's a bad idea too
because that leads to despair what we
should be doing is we should be
confronting our negative emotions we
should be thinking about our negative
emotions and we should be applying a
systematic way to enlist these negative
emotions to help us live better in the
future that's that's the key and the
trouble is nobody ever teaches us how to
do that so there's a there has to be a
distinction between sort of reflection
and
rumination
absolutely rumination is terrible for us
um but the reason that people a reason
that people ruminate a main reason that
people ruminate is they don't know what
to do when a negative emotion comes in
because we're so over indexed in
positivity people think that if they're
experiencing a negative emotion oh my
god everybody else is so positive there
must be something wrong with me and that
can bring them down what's more is that
when they experience a negative emotion
because they're human
they haven't been instructed on what to
do with a negative emotion
and there are ways that we can process
negative emotions far more effectively
and you can arrest that march toward
rumination what should they do then what
should people do
oh well there's all coming there are a
bunch of things that we can do on that i
mean there's there's i mean i like to
look at the process as
inward outward forward inward outward
forward so inward what you have to do
when you experience a regret is you need
to practice something called
self-compassion which is a line of
research that began 20 years ago by
kristen knepp at the university of texas
basically it's this when we look at what
you know and i'm sure your listeners are
probably big violators of this
when we make mistakes when we screw up
the way we talk to ourselves is brutal
we lacerate ourselves we criticize
ourselves in such cruel terms that i
can't imagine that most of us would ever
talk to another human being the way we
talk to ourselves
all right don't do that there's no
evidence that's effective
um there's no evidence that that kind of
severe self-criticism improves
performance in a sense it's what you
were saying earlier it's a little bit
performative for yourself you're
basically virtue signaling to yourself
about what a badass you are and but it
doesn't improve performance what
improves performance and and and i
encourage your listeners to look at this
research on self-compassion because it's
powerful
is what improves performance is this
treating yourself with kindness rather
than contempt basically treating
yourself with the same kindness you
would treat somebody else
who you came to you with this kind of
thing recognizing that your mistakes and
your missteps are part of the human
condition that you're actually in some
level not that special that if that if
you have a regret about oh i should have
started a business you're not alone if
you have regret about mistreating
somebody you're not alone it's part of
the human experience and the third thing
is that
um these regrets these mistakes these
missteps these screw-ups they're a part
of your life they don't fully define
your life um they're a moment in your
life and so when you do that when you
sort of reframe how you think about it
inward that makes the way for that paves
the way for
um you know the other parts of the
reckoning process okay so that's inward
that's inward yeah
outward disclosure
disclosure
there is a lot there's a strong case to
be made for disclosing your regrets
um
for a couple of reasons you know here's
the thing
i'll go let me give you an example so i
got these 18 okay so so i put up this
site with like two tweets i have 15 000
regrets from people all over the country
all over the world
15 000 people saying hello yes hello
complete stranger i would like to tell
you my biggest regret all right so
that's kind of wacky in itself
then i also
um had a uh you know in the forum i said
you know if you wanted
to because i'm you know because i'm a
writer and i'm writing a book about
regret and i said if you wanted to if
you if you'd like to be contacted for a
follow-up interview
but please include your email address
you feel free to include your email
otherwise it was anonymous i thought
that maybe five or six percent of people
would include their email address with
32 included their email address 32 said
yes i want to tell my complete stranger
my regret and i want him to email me so
we can talk more about it okay that's
that's telling us something right there
and so what is it about disclosure okay
we got the inward reframing let's go
outward disclosure is an unburdening
there's no question about that but the
other thing about disclosure
and this is extremely important is that
disclosure is an integral part of the
sense making process
and the reason for that is that the way
we can there are different ways we can
construe things we can construe them to
oversimplify a bit at an abstract level
or a concrete level and their advantages
and disadvantages and those different
levels of construal so
negative emotion emotions in general but
negative emotions especially are
abstract they're blobby they're
amorphous they feel menacing because of
that when you convert those menacing
emotions to words
spoken or written
they're more concrete
concrete things are less medicine
so you defend them in a way and then the
fact that they're in language allows you
to begin making sense of them so that's
disclosure so so if you're if you're if
they're we we
we overstate how much disclosing our
vulnerabilities will affect how people
think of us in general there's 30 years
of research saying that when we disclose
our mistakes and our screw-ups and our
vulnerabilities people actually think
more highly of us not less highly of us
um so but even if you're skittish about
disclosing what you should be doing is
just give me if you write about your
regret for 15 minutes a day for three
days that's an incredibly potent way to
make sense of the regret so that's
outward the next step is forward you've
got to extract a lesson from it
you've got to extract a lesson from it
and the way we extract lessons is is by
getting some distance from it it's
pretty clear
it's essentially incontrovertible that
we are
better at solving
we stink at solving our own problems and
are pretty good at selling other
people's problems
and that's all that's all because of
distance so you can do things like
talk to yourself in the third person uh
a lot of research on that so so for you
if you have a regret instead of saying
what should i do you should say what
should chris do
um there are things uh you can use our
time travel skills and you can say
you're deciding what to do or how to how
to extract a lesson from this regret
make a phone call to the chris of 2032
and say hey chris of 2032. what do you
want me to do in response to this regret
the chris of 2032 has a pretty freaking
good idea because he's not enmeshed in
the chris of 2022. um you could even do
something like the the just the very
simple technique of saying this is good
for all decisions
you're you're trying to decide what to
do ask yourself what would i tell my
best friend to do
when you put when you when when you do
that people always know what to do what
it's so that's distance so you want to
refrain treat yourself with kindness
rather than contempt you want to
disclose in order to concretize it and
make sense of it and then you want to
take a step back and extract a lesson
from it that you can apply the next time
and when we do that negative emotions
they still hurt a little bit but they
don't destroy us
and we actually kind of we in some ways
we co-opt them we we we enlist them
integrating make us better and we and we
avoid
repeating those negative emotions later
on
did you look at
when it comes to
disclosing a difference between writing
for yourself versus writing for someone
else speaking to yourself versus having
a conversation with somebody else
i didn't look at that a lot of the
research on writing is is writing only
for yourself
um and and the disclosure so so
when we talk about disclosure
the the the verbal disclosure is almost
always to somebody else but at the same
point to yourself the written disclosure
is almost always only to yourself um so
i don't know about whether you know
writing an essay and publishing an essay
about your regrets my hunch and it's
only a punch is that um
it would be as useful if not more useful
than simply speaking about it because
the very act of writing is a form of
sense making and so you might make
greater sense of it by writing about it
and then the disclosure gives you both
the unburdening and allows you to build
affinity and in some ways puts your
issue out to other people who
then you can enlist in deciding what to
do and figure out what to do next i
really like the the disclosure element
of that that concretizing and defanging
of whatever it is that you feel i i
think i
i accuse the um
american imperial measurement system of
basically being the same thing that you
guys don't actually know how much
something weighs it's just a notion
about what it might be it's in this
region right you know it's it's pounds
it's stones it's a whatever like it's
it's just a thing and i kind of feel
like undisclosed thoughts a lot of the
time or ideas it's one of the reasons i
love writing a newsletter i've never had
newsletter for ages and now it's just a
thousand words at the end of the week
but it forces me to concretize something
that i've really been thinking about for
the last week and i speak i speak for
you know hours hours four or five hours
a week on the show it's different
something different i agree between
writing
and speaking
there's a greater there's a greater
rigor to it correct uh yes particularly
when you know it's going to be consumed
elsewhere and this is something that i
just this is something that i discovered
long ago it's actually one of no joke
one of the most important lessons i've
learned which is
that writing
like we tend to think that what you do
is you figure stuff out and then you
write about it but writing itself is a
form of figuring out writing itself is a
form of figuring out what you think uh
and and again the broader kind of
academic term i i'll use for that
because i think it's useful i don't know
if anybody else cares but
it's sense making we're trying to make
sense of things and the way that we make
sense of things is by
is by
being able to shift between these two
levels of construal between looking at
things abstractly and looking at things
concretely the same thing is true when
it comes to the the research on
self-distancing and problem solving
you know what one of the things we have
to do there is that we we want to
construe things when we look at our own
problems we're like scuba divers right
scuba divers don't know anything about
the ocean but they know a little bit
about the ocean but what they know is
like what's around them right there they
have no sense for the sweep for the
ecosystem of the ocean so you don't want
to be when you're
when we go into our own problems we
scuba divers and the way you solve
problems is you want to be an
oceanographer and so you need to
actually affirmatively take steps to
zoom out and look at things differently
is sense making in the literature now as
a term
yeah oh yeah no it's it's not my term
it's it's it's there it's a term that
gets used a lot in the space that i'm in
yeah in the podcasting space it's mostly
to do with uh
cultural issues what does it mean to
understand how the world operates
outside of institutions when you can't
trust the news organizations and the
government and blah blah blah but it's
interesting to find out that it's
actually a legitimate term that exists
within the literature too
absolutely absolutely i mean there's um
you know there are there are some
interesting papers in organizational
behavior about sense making
organizations carl for your listeners
carl like wbi ck has done some work on
how we make sense of
uh how we make sense of situations as as
groups how we make sense of
events and situations and emotions as um
organizations so it's a it's a term but
i but i think that it i think that what
i think human beings are sense makers we
have it is this very confusing chaotic
world that we're trying to navigate and
we're trying to figure it out we're
trying to make sense of it and
the way you make sense of things is not
singular that is you don't do it only
abstractly only concretely you do it
both you don't do it only on the
specific or only on the general you do
it both
um you don't do it you don't you don't
you do it not only looking back but also
looking forward that is you need some
dexterity in order to make in order to
make sense
what is the fourth category of regrets
fourth category are connection regrets
and these are regrets about
relationships all relationships not
only romantic relationships in fact most
of them were not romantic relationships
relationships about
among um
you know parents to kids kiss the
parents siblings relatives friends
neighbors colleagues and essentially the
story there is that you have a
relationship that was intact or should
have been intact and it comes apart
and it usually just drifts apart it
doesn't
explode apart and
it drifts apart one side wants to reach
out it doesn't
because they say
it's going to be really awkward to reach
out and the other side's not going to
care
and so it drifts apart more and the
trouble there is that they're wrong
it's
reaching out is often not awkward at all
and the other side almost always cares
and so
the connection regrets are if only i'd
reached out
and they reflect our need for affinity
for connection for love
i bet as well if you were to ask the
people that said they won't care if i
reach out and you said to them well what
about if they reached out to you or how
would you feel these people would say
well i'd love it it'd be fantastic
it would be brilliant it would
completely erode all of the worry and
the concern
and yet
they are enable unable to extrapolate
from their experience because we tend to
think that we are much more special than
we really are
you know i mean one of one of one of the
one of the things that we one of the
things that we labor under one of the
things that constrains us uh in our
ability to navigate the world and make
sense of it is something called
pluralistic ignorance where we think
that
we have a belief but no one else shares
it
um no one else yeah i'm so special no
one else shares that belief i mean you
see it you see it i mean i always i
always think i i think about it in i
think about it in school so the
professor gives a lecture
and and she says are there any questions
and
you know
you're saying oh my god i'm totally
confused i don't understand this i don't
understand that but no one else is
asking questions so they must understand
and i don't want to look like an idiot
when in fact they you didn't say well
maybe they're thinking the exact same
thing they don't want to look like like
an idiot so we tend to think that we are
much more special than we really are but
it's safe to assume if you have a
thought it's safe to assume that some
non-zero number of other people have
also had that thought
or might be having that thought right
now
um and so you know we have to be
again it's part of this toggling in the
sense-making sometimes you are unique
sometimes what you're feeling and
thinking and seeing is unique and
idiosyncratic to you
sometimes it's extraordinarily common
and it's much more common than we
it's much more common than we think we
have sort of an illusion of our own
you know our own specialness and and
again i don't want to
hamper anybody's self-esteem listening
to this you're all very special but
you're also
like a lot of other people i'm like a
lot of other people
i'm surprised by the
pre well actually before i say what i'm
surprised by what were you most
surprised came up as a common regret
i'm not surprised i'm not sure i'm
surprised by any particular thing that
came up
um i think what i was surprised by more
was the universality of these regrets
right by how common they were across
especially across nations
um how how little seeming national
difference there was in a lot of these
regrets
i'm surprised by the bullying
i'm surprised
by how many people it makes sense in
retrospect i didn't bully anybody in
school so i
maybe it's just my um lack of
pluralistic ignorance
um
yeah i i just it surprises me that
that many people
felt like they'd bullied someone
i don't know how many bullies there were
in my school maybe
but i suppose you don't it's not like
you need to be a bully it's not it's not
it's some label hello i am the bully i
will punch you in the face it's one
incident perhaps that sticks with people
they'll have done one thing at one time
stole money from some kid's lunch box
one day and that's the thing that stays
with them it can be a perfect student
throughout all of time except for that
i was a little surprised by that but
when they first started coming into the
database but then it's like this is a
it's a very common regret and and at
some level i'm kind of heartened by it
i'm kind of heartened by the fact that
people who mistreated others
regret it 10 years later 20 years later
30 years later i mean it suggests that
they've learned something that
that their values are being clarified
and that it's giving them some guidance
on what to do next
it is it is strange i wonder what
someone is is hoping to do there look i
hurt somebody in the past
if i do this again in future this isn't
the sort of person that i want to be i i
have this vision of myself as a
integral integrity laden human that is
going to feel proud yet
it's an interesting one
does agency relate to regret at all the
ability to
have impact on a situation or not
agency is is critical to regret agency
is is is essential to regret you can't
have regret if you don't feel the sense
if you don't have any agency
so you know you can you can you can look
at it like okay so
um
you know i'm looking out the window here
in chicago and
it's not it's it's a very overcast day
and maybe i would prefer that it was a
sunny day but i can't regret that it's
not sunny
i'm disappointed that it's not sunny but
i can't regret that because regret
requires agency i don't control whether
the sun shines or not um and so
agency is agency is incredibly important
that's one reason why it hurts so much
is because it's your fault
disappointment is not your fault
the line gets blurred though between
what we know is our fault and what we
know we have agency over and what we
don't if you get hit by a car your
belief that i coulda would have should
have looked to the left reversed back
from the you know and then some
catastrophe occurs
you can regret that
despite having not had any agency over
this idiot driver that just hit you but
believing that you did
exactly right and sorting that out is
incredibly important let me give you an
example of that from the survey from the
quantitative survey so i was i wanted to
tease out this question of
agency and i also wanted to tease out
this question of if you believe if you
believe purely in fatalism
then you don't have regret
um
you know because if you have a purely
fatalistic view of the world you
there's no there's no agency and
therefore there's no regret and so i
wanted to see where people what the what
the ratio is so so i asked in this
quantitative survey of the us population
i asked a question about free will
i said
i i said you believe in general that
people have free will they have some
control over you know what they do how
they did it okay huge majority said yes
i believe in free will okay then
elsewhere in the survey i asked the sort
of sneaked in the opposite question
which is
you think that in general everything in
life happens for a reason it's a more
fatalistic thing and
almost everybody said yes and so what
you had is people believing in both of
these things and it's frustrating okay
you're you're rubbing your face in
frustration i
buried my hands my face and my hands in
frustration thinking this is
contradictory but
it might not be because that's what our
lives are like we don't there aren't
clear i mean you said it just now there
isn't there can be a
fuzzy border between where we have
agency and where we have not and sorting
that out is part of it and so you have
these people who believe both in free
will and that everything happens for a
reason i think that that's part of what
it takes to navigate our lives and
that's one of the other things that
regret teaches us it forces us to sort
that out where did i have agency where
was i a victim of circumstance you can
look at this in narrative terms too i
mean
dan adams who is a um
who is a um
personality psychologist at northwestern
university up the road from where i am
right now
he
says that we forge our identities in
narrative terms and
and there are two kinds of narratives in
our lives one is what he calls a
contamination narrative which is where
things go from good to bad
the other is a redemption area where
things go from bad to good and people
who are healthy people who learn and
grow and progress see their lives in
terms of redemption narratives not as
perfect but as better as going in that
in that kind of trajectory and so when
we think about these our lives and
narrative terms we inevitably have to
ask the question okay my life is a
narrative am i the author of that
narrative or am i a character in that
narrative and the answer is yes
you're both
and you have to try to sort that out and
that is that you know again this is like
we're we're having you know the
sense-making hour with chris williamson
but that is also a part of
what it takes to
make sense of the world where do you
have agency where do you where you know
and i think what's interesting about
this emotion of regret that is
unpleasant and that we try to avoid and
that we try to bat away is that when we
actually reckon with it it leads us into
discussions like this it leads us into
discussions about what we can control
and what we can it leads us into
discussions about how we make sense of
our life it leads us into discussions
about what makes life worth living and
so if we actually treat this emotion
like grown-ups rather than run away from
it or ruminate over it
it is instructive and it's clarifying
is there an implication in this that the
way we should live life
is in a way that minimizes our regrets
in future
i think that's true to a a point
because you can't minimize every regret
that's the key you can't minimize every
regret so if you're trying to go around
minimizing every regret you're going to
go you're going to go nuts you have to
be able to minimize the right regrets
and once again these this chorus of 16
17 18 000 people is telling us
what
they regret and they tend to regret the
same thing so so you know if you say
okay what am i going to have for dinner
i'm going to try to minimize my regret
about having dinner so i'm going to i'm
going to have more regret about having
fried chicken or am i going to have more
regret about having meatloaf tonight
the you the me
let's take me the me of five years from
now is not gonna give a [ __ ] one way or
another i can guarantee you that like if
i could get the me of 2027 on the phone
and call him up and say okay
he's gonna say dan i don't care
i have completely forgotten that evening
five years ago it has no material effect
on my life but if i say i'm here in
chicago and let's say i have an old
friend in chicago and
i haven't talked to him for a while
and i said oh i should reach out but
it's going to be kind of weird if i
reach out uh okay i'm not gonna
the dan of 2027 will tell me hey dude
reach out
because i'm gonna regret this in five
years if you don't reach out right now
and so we should try to minimize our
regrets but we should try to minimize
the right ones and it ends up being a
relatively small set of regrets that we
should be minimizing so we should be in
some sense maximizing on minimizing
those regrets and essentially saying
good enough is good enough and
you know whether you have fried chicken
or meat love tonight whether you buy a
great car or a blue car
those kinds of things ultimately don't
matter the you of the future is not
going to care one way or another i would
say that over a shorter time span you
may be able to see those uh come out a
little bit more tightly you know when
you're looking at anything over 20 years
there's maybe what between five and a
hundred decisions that are probably
going to stick out that you might
actually be able to remember but if you
were to say i'm supposed to be on a diet
i'm on a diet because in future i want
to be somebody that's fit i have the
choice this evening between some nice
steamed salmon and asparagus or the
fried chicken
what would me tomorrow want me today to
do
to me tomorrow is going to say well i
feel a bit
lethargic here and and i was my
performance in the gym wasn't very good
and i didn't sleep too well
i i i read that i agree with that i mean
i think that that the perspective
changes with with
a little bit with the distance but i
think that future you i think that
future you is generally interested in
generally has your best interest in mind
i really do
um i think that the situation there is
is
in that particular instance is to change
the choice architecture so you don't
even so you don't even have to make a
decision
so the only thing
exactly the only thing you're offered is
something that is good for you
i asked jordan peterson this question
the other day i'm going to ask you as
well because i feel like it kind of
relates to what we're talking about here
i asked him
whether there is a value in life of
having a nemesis of having an enemy
someone or someone or something that
motivates you because
many of us me included trying to live a
life of peace and not make enemies of
people or things or ideas or groups or
whatever
but
i can't deny myself that when i have
resentment in my heart there is an extra
degree of fire that gets lit underneath
me that i want to prove that person or
idea or thing or whatever
wrong that that amount of motivation and
drive
comes from a place that is really really
difficult for me to tap into and it's
the the juvenile lower resolution
shitty vibration version of myself
however it's true right when i resent
something or someone i put my foot down
on the gas and i'm wondering whether um
to tie it into what we've spoken about
today whether regrets can also fill that
hole whether regret can act as that fire
it can almost act as a not an
ideological nemesis but like a you know
a nemesis against the situation that
you've been in the past
well i mean i think that let's let's
let's take on this this notion of
nemesis and and we can think about it in
terms of our personal lives but we can
also think about it in
in a broader narrative why do so many
stories
hit
the hero against the nemesis because
what is that what's the what's the
narrative function of that nemesis the
narrative function of the nemesis is to
clear is to
is to present an obstacle in the way of
a goal
and it's also to clarify
who the the hero is and so
it's not that exactly exactly and so
it's so so if one feels that one has a
nemesis
and that when they're in the and you're
reasonably
psychologically well adjusted you're not
creating phantoms and
this you know you're not paranoid um if
you feel like you have a nemesis um
that is telling you something if if
something presents as a nemesis it's
telling you
what you value
and not that as you say and it's also
telling you what your goal is which is
to
bypass that nemesis or to overcome that
nemesis so it can be clarified this is
in some ways why
something like envy which is a pretty
bad emotion to have there's not a lot of
positive and it's pretty useless as well
yeah
and but it but envy can be clarifying
that if you feel envy you say okay what
am i really envying here like why am i
feeling this way what is it that is
causing this envy and it's a
clarification of
it's a clarification of what you value
i think with envy it's an interrogation
of what you value rather than a
clarification of it you have to ask
yourself okay why do i feel envy what is
it do i admire this person's clothing do
i admire this do i my this person's
um i don't know professional success do
i admire this person's wealth um
and how you have to interrogate that how
important is that really to
how important is that really to me but
um
but but but again yeah it's an interest
it's a it's a it's an interesting
question i don't i don't i don't know if
i have a nemesis i never literally never
thought about that
but um
i guess if i do have a
um a nemesis it would be
things that we believe that aren't they
just aren't true
and trying to
because that bugs me
if when we believe that no regrets
and you should never look backward is a
an appropriate and healthy blueprint for
life that's just wrong and so maybe that
that false belief is a negative you know
things that things that are
things that people believe that just are
not true maybe operates as a nemesis for
me
it's so strange because regret is a
topic is an uncomfortable one it's it's
it's not nice for people to experience
it's not that even thinking about
regrets as a topic itself is generally
kind of a bit icky and discordant
and yet
it is you have convinced me that it's a
gift you've convinced me that what a
regret does
is it shows us the direction
in which we don't want to go in future
and that even at the time the way that
we interpret situations is often at the
mercy of our cognitive biases and what
we see blah blah
but over time with the benefit of a
little bit of perspective you actually
end up thinking okay well what are the
things that stuck about what are the
things that i actually did or didn't
care about what are the things that i
actually wish that i had or hadn't done
differently
and those that arise
you don't need to do sense making in the
moment because your system has a lot has
filtered everything out except for the
stuff that is left you know like um
somebody that's sifting for gold or
whatever in a river okay what's left
what's left is the thing that didn't go
away with time that's the thing that you
still need to work on in future this is
going to be the same thing if the
situation happens again
amen hallelujah
i have nothing to add to that it's
perfectly said
you're exactly right
daniel pink ladies and gentlemen people
want to keep up to date with what it is
that you're doing why should they harass
you on the internet
they can go to my website which is dan
pink.com
d-a-n-p-i-n-k.com that we got a
newsletter um
uh all kinds of other stuff uh we use
free lots of lots of free resources on
the website uh information about the
books all kinds of groovy stuff dope
thanks dan
thank you chris that was super
interesting what's happening people
thank you very much for tuning in if you
enjoyed that episode then press here for
a selection of the best clips from the
podcast over the last few weeks and
don't forget to subscribe
peace